[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um eric friedman is a professor and dean
of the school of media arts at columbia
college chicago he's the author most
recently of the persistence of code in
game engine culture which um i think
it's 2020 um you
uh so that oh so it is out because yes
22. um
and as well as transient images personal
media and public frameworks 2011
he serves on the editorial board of the
international journal of creative media
research and the advisory board of the
communication and media studies research
network
so i'm going to hand it off to professor
freeman thank you for joining us today
thanks it's uh thanks heather it's great
to be here um i appreciate uh being
hosted uh and to talk about uh some new
work uh this is
part but not part of my uh my next or
the book that i'm currently on deadline
for which is on artificial intelligence
and playable media
but it sort of fits between these spaces
between the work that i was doing on
video game market
architectures and artificial
intelligence
i must say that um
the
some of this was written
or conceived of in my head with a
particular type of audience so
i don't know the context of the
graduate student body so how much you
know and don't know
so some of this may be too rudimentary
some of it may be too advanced but sort
of let me know when we get to that sort
of point of the uh
sort of conversation if i
if i need to clarify anything that i've
spoken about i'm going to share my
screens i've got some
things for us to look at along the way
um
and i will share my sound as well
there you go and
i hope you can all see that in here
there's nothing in here yet but you can
all see that
so um i'm going to be talking about
the role that
the influence of video game technologies
have had on both game and non-game media
and their design and development
environments and runtime components
are software systems that are known as
game engines
and they've promoted a wide range of
uses for real-time 3d visualization
that extend far beyond the field of
video game development
the software systems that drive video
games have provided a common framework
for digital content creation
across what were distinct once distinct
media verticals film television even
manufacturing and industrial fabrication
architecture and urban planning and
other interactive media forms including
digital twins
any form that can leverage
photorealistic visual effects and
program programmable software generated
assets
so what we see is that game engines are
influencing just about every aspect of
for example the film and television
production pipeline uh
including pre-visualization
advanced in-camera visual effects all of
the all these things are complementing
what was once the solitary purview of
post-production
what we see in film and television
production is more and more directors
and cinematographers are working in
tandem with digital imaging technicians
you know popular tv programs like the
mandalorian
this crowd probably knows uh or
westworld um have leveraged game engine
technologies throughout their respective
production processes
to seamlessly integrate physical and
virtual assets
and both series have used elaborate
filmmaking techniques to
map and capture virtual settings
rendered in real time across
custom-built led walls while recording
live performers
um and while game engines are being used
across media forms they were built as
development tools for interactive
digital content creation
and really as code frameworks to
formally define the field of play
meaning the game environment and its
assets as well as the executable
functions meaning what happens during
game play uh you know throughout video
games
they're the building blocks for
efficient real-time visualization
and their programming is continuing to
influence a broader and broader swath of
visual culture that's why i think it's
important to talk about these structures
uh video game engines you know have a
lot to do with powering our visual
futures you know as data and visuality
continue to converge software
development companies that include unity
technologies and epic games
the latter of which i'll focus on today
are rapidly iterating their products to
tackle new marketplaces and they have
plans in fact to colonize the metaverse
many of the images that we consume and
interact with are really artfully
crafted engineered media borne by
these environments or these ecosystems
of hardware software and programming
so in this um
reading what i want to do is you know
examine a tool that's fairly new uh to
the arsenal of video game developer epic
games and that's the meta human creator
uh the metahuman creator which is part
of epic's proprietary unreal engine
was revealed in february 2021 and
subsequently released in april of the
same year through the developers early
access program the application which is
free features uh an accessible user
interface
and it allows game developers and 3d
content creators to quickly build high
fidelity digital humans and i'll just
play their promo video to the sense of
sort of how this tool works and what
they're pitching
i could be one of many
[Music]
you create the narrative
i
am metahuman
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so the questions that i'm posing in my
analysis that i'm not necessarily
looking to answer today but
are the metahuman creator and similar uh
simplified building tools democratizing
the field of digital content creation
which is sort of what epic is pitching
you know in this easy access
familiar user interface um are they also
fostering more diverse representations
and narratives and are they supporting
the free play of identity and playable
media
so these tools which include the entire
unreal engine suite you know shape
visual culture by translating it into a
data set that can be manipulated by an
algorithm
and what we have is digital content
developers can transform visual
artifacts whether it be environments or
objects and characters
in real time with simple user interface
controls such as draggable assets and
variable or numeric sliders
and these tools represent a way of
seeing and knowing the world
and the representations they produce are
part of these hermetically sealed and
privately held encoding processes that
include a company's original data its
application programming its proprietary
build environment and its interface
so for me software and platform studies
as critical approaches to the theories
and practices of computing might help us
unpack both the promise and the perils
of epic's a sophisticated character
generator
the metahuman creator is after all it's
a data-driven software system
it's an analytical engine it's an
integrated system of calculation and
design and it can sculpt and transform
its source data and streamline this
production process of digital humans
um for those of you are not familiar how
this system works the metahuman creator
it's a cloud streamed a web-based
application that lets content developers
create these high-fidelity digital
characters without really being steeped
in the technical processes of things
like character generation uh rigging
animation and other in-engine real-time
functionality it provides a truly rapid
method for developing 3d character
models that can be animated with a
variety of other programs like autodesk
maya and it draws from as its foundation
a library of scans of real people and
then allows 3d content developers to
quickly create these unique photo
realistic
fully rigged digital humans by mixing
together different parts of real people
while changing each character's facial
textures and geometries
and simultaneously updating the
underlying rig so it holds on to the
actual mechanics of the underlying rig
and the library as it stands now
includes a number of prefabricated
metahuman presets
that represent the generalized and
rather soft contours of race ethnicity
gender diversity and a broad spectrum of
individualized skin tones textures
physiognomies and style types
and the tool allows visual artists to
really rapidly and seamlessly as you saw
in that clip manipulate a character's
facial features adjust things like skin
complexion select from a range of preset
body types and styles and then each
finished character can be exported again
fully rigged meaning fully functional
movable and ready to animate within
epic's unreal engine and that's part of
their uh license game licensing
agreement to utilize these characters
within the unreal engine
so from a technical standpoint the
process collapses more traditional
scanning to rig development pipelines
and wraps the creative process in a very
familiar user interface to really
facilitate the design process for those
unreal those who are developing inside
the unreal engine
and for that reason it really promises
to advance the field of virtual
production for games and other immersive
experience
experiences and fields that draw from
these high fidelity and responsibly
responsibly animated virtual assets and
digital doubles
i have this slide on the screen because
i think the tool also animates some of
the cultural politics of the face
generating algorithm that was vividly
illustrated on this cover of time
magazine back in 1993
which was a composite of the new face of
america created from a
computer-generated mix of individuals
from several racial and ethnic groups
in this particularly you know seamless
synthesis designed to illustrate how
immigrants are shaping the united states
in a multicultural society really belies
the work involved you know conceals the
police the policy decisions you know
conceals the socioeconomic divides
and conceals the myriad forces of
disenfranchisement that impede such a
very seamless vision of progress so all
of those sort of obstacles barriers
boundaries
you know margins are obscured by sort of
the fascination with what we can do on
the cert with surface algorithms
i'd say meta-human creation also shares
an awkward legacy in its dependence on
deeply multi-layered algorithmic
manipulation with visual trickery and
disinformation which is an unfortunate
byproduct of of gans gans which are
generative adversarial networks and gans
are a type of machine learning that uses
a pair of artificial intelligence
algorithms
in a large volume of data to try and
accurately replicate real-world image
patterns until the fakes are
indistinguishable from the originals
one of the results of advanced gan
research is the ability to develop
unique human faces that can pass for
real people and collectively these
systems are rendering visual culture
from a perspective that as it advances
is actually less and less determined by
human intervention although it was
originally conceived and developed from
within an anthropo anthropocentric
design perspective and is inherently
prone to humanistic bias
these representations again are not
simply happening within their own
platforms but they are impacting the
visual grammar the organizational labor
the technical structures the industrial
models of film television gaming related
media forms
for those of you who aren't familiar
with how gans work it requires training
i said two algorithms a generator and a
discriminator so in this process you
actually have ai competing against
itself the generator learns to create
plausible data
while the the latter the discriminator
learns to discriminate between the
generators fake data and real data until
the process becomes almost um
much more seamless
much more competent and capable of
generally generating realistic images
voices videos any of you who have seen
the fake tom cruise videos you know and
suggests the goal of intelligence
research may be twofold how do we
simulate intel human intelligence to
such a degree that
machines might replace human beings as
part of the process and occupy their
locations within an organization so we
no longer need the real actor
and it's also about a representational
framework or development pipeline that
also sort of displaces human labor and
allows machines to carry out these these
sort of design tasks
for those of you i'll give you sort of a
little background
in 2018 a team of uh nvidia technology
researchers proposed style gan
and stylegan is a style based
generative architecture
that is tasked with analyzing and
synthesizing existing facial image data
to produce these novel photorealistic
images i'll give you a sort of brief
sort of clip here so you understand how
these style gans actually work with
human faces
[Music]
we're going to get too technical so i'll
stop it there um uh but uh
for those of you who may not actually
have looked at the nvidia's research um
this style gan this technology that was
being developed by nvidia uh became the
sort of uh
um architecture for um what uh software
engineer philip wang used in 2019
he used because the style gand is an
open source generator so the same
technology developed by nvidia is used
in an open source model
by philip wang to create this person
does not exist
and this is just a sampling of the
images from this person does not exist
for those who haven't checked out the
website
this person does not exist is a website
that conjures its fake portraits from
existing image data and produces new
human faces every time that you refresh
the page so the style gan is operating
the background every time you hit click
refresh a new face
of a fake person will be generated
and this data driven image modeling this
is just sort of seven selective faces
from from uh this person does not exist
this data driven image modeling is based
on always a degree of normalization
that's how the algorithm works how do we
train the algorithm on existing data
sets and output the information in ways
that match stylistic social conventions
and expectations so the goal of the
system roa is sort of normalizing to you
know
to create an unsupervised image to image
translation and the production of a
novel image that conforms to common
facial shapes
and common facial features so you never
get anything you know unbelievable or
radicalized you know as a result of this
process that's sort of the modeling at
work so the style gan in every case
operates within and produces what we
would consider as acceptable structures
and while it's a fascinating visual tool
it carries with it as i'm sure you sense
much starker undercurrents
ai tools are being deployed with
institut within institutions that are
historically marked by systemic
discrimination you know in housing in
the workplace and the criminal justice
system our financial institutions
and bias is baked into the outcomes of
what ai is constantly asked to do and
predict
um the data used to train machine
intelligence is often under
representative of people of color of
women and of other marginalized groups
and those fault lines impact the design
development implementation of
outcomes of ai
across a broad range of tech and tech
indep and tech dependent industries
where it really becomes more difficult
to extract what's happening meaning to
extract the signaling processes embedded
in the automated systems that are
designed to create more efficient
workflows and more realistic images
and while what i've shown you including
the meta human creator doesn't really
rely on ai per se and is instead focused
on the physical aspects of character
creation
these assets are primed for intelligence
uses as non-player characters driven by
ai subsystems or as intelligent agents
in a wider array of video game and game
adjacent environments
so since it's launched the metahuman
creator has been successfully coupled
with an ai voice actor platform
developed by replica studios that
enables developers to create ai
characters that look and sound human
where we have voice actors training the
ai how to perform so we have this sort
of whole hermetic system about how
characters look and what they sound like
that is all has a human component as its
base
but again those sort of uh those systems
are then concealed in the actual ongoing
output which where ai slowly but surely
takes over the performative dimension of
character
and while it's a unique enterprise i
believe the human the metahuman creator
carries the cultural weight of all of
these other simulation systems
intelligent or not that approximate
human subjects
um again as i said meta-human creator is
a fluid process that really shortens the
timeline to produce its human character
assets
and it streamlines the overall
development pipeline so there's a
there's a labor implication here as well
um
the people who use or work with
metahuman creator are never given direct
access to the primary scan library in
its data so there is an existing library
of original human scans but instead what
you're asked to do is
work with and select from a cast of
metahuman preset characters that are
artifacts of that library and composite
representations of its raw data so
reading the tool from a sort of critical
vantage point rather than a purely
industrial vantage point in this sort of
speedy transformation of character rigs
and other non-binary attributes
this ability to blend between characters
highlights what i believe is the sort of
potential queerness or openness of data
yet most commercial demonstrations of
this tool
speed through all these mutable subjects
ultimately to land on a predictable end
result of fixed results so a dynamic
creative process ultimately has to yield
to some sort of stasis
to the construction of a functional and
fixed character build of a certain
physionomic type so the the image
library which is a really complex data
set
has to constantly behave in plausible
ways and according to a number of marked
constraints to produce these
anatomically believable outputs and
while code may be fluid
and sort of not have any anatomical
fixity these things always wind up
becoming much more constricted if our
goal if our intent is to produce
believable high-quality digital
characters
um all of the meta-humans use an
underlying skeleton asset um so while
their
facial features may be unique the the
features of
defined body face hair and clothes
all of these are parented to a governing
skeletal mesh and those structures allow
the
external features of these characters to
be purposefully animated and readily
swapped so these distinct bodies that
are pulled from the library and blended
together to make custom custom assets
now always remain functionally locked to
an underlying mesh
so
even the external skins of these
characters can be readily swapped out so
this female character and another male
character
share may share the same underlying
skeletal rig so a process of animation
retargeting
enables animations to be reused between
characters who have the same skeleton
asset even if they have different
proportions or additional bones as as
long as they share the same bone
hierarchy and use the same rig to pass
animation data from one skeleton to
another so even the specificity of
character type as as gets locked into a
model
you know becomes swappable based on the
skeletal asset that drives the motion of
all of these characters in the same way
um
some of the questions that you know i
sort of raised throughout my research is
you know these meta-humans are designed
intelligently but they don't possess
intelligence they look real i don't know
i don't really know if they are uncanny
or not i don't know if they truly evoke
an emotional response you know their
facial features their geometries their
expressions their movements are all
plausible since they're tied to that
underlying skeletal rig
but they would need another programming
layer another ai subsystem to really
give them agency to really make them
semi-autonomous contextually driven and
motivated characters but i think that's
the prompt that's really posed by epic
games in that commercial reveal video
that asks us or commands us
you create the narrative so these are
sort of primed for sort of narrative
appropriation
and while these assets are still in need
of a narrative i think we can still read
them as meaningful traces of a
particular industrial process which is
all about an ongoing push toward hyper
realism in commercial media that has
created a visual economy that is now
supported by an industrial apparatus
that privileges
how we master these tools of production
and where the bodies and the politics
are often cleaved in the design process
and there's an interesting sort of
conversation among unreal developers
where they ask you know each other like
who is your favorite meta human
character and and they choose based on
you know this sort of
very sort of whimsical like um like sort
of
sort of visual reading of these
characters that they pursue produced
which are really sort of
sharply de-politicized uh you know in in
in just in terms of a like
let's choose as they do in
in the selection video around this
character let's choose this character or
that character let's sort of just mix
them to mix them up together
so this what i see is you know epics
multi-ethnic multi-racial
even transgender metahuman creator
is from a unreal or epic games
perspective really just a design tool
not a narrative engine the transitions
are simple and seamless
and the traces of non-binary and
non-white identities are simply part of
a larger color parrot color palette of
various ethnicities and genders in the
database so i think the metahuman
creators really mastered cosmetic
diversity
and the rather quick fabrication of
multiculturalism
and it seems to suggest that technology
can be colorblind and embrace a certain
in-betweenness
the rapid transitions that we see
between subject positions is really a
masterful visual spectacle that seems
incompatible with any genuine concern
for the difficulties of lived lived
experience
uh or you know lived experienced with
difficult body boundaries although
ethics developers suggest that the
quality and fidelity of its metahumans
can create player empathy so i think
what we see in meta-human creation is a
really feat or spectacle of bodily
governance of regulating flow
of regulating discrete bodies and the
power and privilege associated with with
this particular tool
is not simply about how humans are
represented but who produces these
representations and who owns these
bodies at the end of the day
because meta-human creation requires a
certain degree of technical know-how
as well as the requisite processing
power as well as the requisite network
access
uh with and the the necessary unreal
engine supports to run these real-time
renders
um and at the same time if we step back
a bit we know that the metahuman creator
and its unreal engine parent meaning
epic games they sit within existing
relations
that guarantee the almost inequitable
distribution of an access to technology
this application is based on and
requires epic's proprietary pixel
streaming technology that can pull data
from its central server
and it's part of the
in this
is in part the product of the company's
uh acquisition of of a serbian-based
company
three lateral which pulled the
technology for crafting these virtual
humans closer to the unreal engine
by adding three laterals you know
research on volumetric facial capture
and facial rigging to epic's portfolio
so what we see in epic is a constant
sort of acquisition cycle of what do we
need we need three lateral we need to
capitalize on volumetric facial capture
let's pull this company into our orbit
we need sort of stronger networking
power or server power or data draws so
let's work with our pixel streaming
technology so it does indeed become the
sort of real
um
um sort of hermetic sort of data driven
ecosystems
and as i as i suggested the metahuman
presets
or the series of characters that are
based on 3d scans of real people these
were built from a data set that required
a significant you know
number of cameras a significant number
of processing power to create complete
3d models of real human faces and in
this case three lateral provided the
resources for epic games to accomplish
this task but we don't know who provided
the raw materials that make up this sort
of racial and ethnic and gender mix of
the unreal database
we don't know how precisely these
individuals were arranged and
transformed into these preset meta-human
characters because the library that you
are choosing from is one step removed
multiple steps removed from that initial
sort of library scan of real human faces
these are synthesized to begin with and
you are
basing a model around
pre-synthesized character sets
um
so what we see and this is sort of what
i what you may understand is being
represented here
in this particular slide end users
choose
one or more meta-human presets from the
database
of pre-made characters this is simply a
sampling of some of these pre-made
characters
from the um unreal engine database
so end-use end users can choose one or
more of these meta-human presets or
character assets from this database and
again there are at this point a library
of more than 50 named individuals so all
of these individuals organized
alphabetically from ada to zen they all
are uniquely named
and you can then create your metahuman
uh by enabling the applications blend
mode so what you do is you can then
choose uh additional character presets
and drag and drop these 3d portrait
models into a concentric circle around
the primary preset in this what you see
represented here is the application
viewport so in this case there's one
primary preset in the center you know
three additional character presets on
that are orbiting in the concentric
circle and then using viewport you can
sort of choose your blend you know you
know and start to sort of move elements
of all these concentric characters into
the primary character reset
and you can then map their facial
features onto one another and this is
again always designed to produce
plausible results from the database as
it as it outputs what are custom blends
of digital uh digital individuals
one other sort of interesting sort of
element is once you get done
constructing your your fabricated sort
of model
is that um unreal engines live link face
app allows developers to capture live
facial performance with an iphone or
ipad and map that performance in real
time to their meta human characters uh
so
in this case you see from lucas ridley
you know uh one of his tutorial he is in
the lower right hand corner the um the
um live link face app is represented on
his phone next to him in this case what
he's doing is he's capturing his facial
performance
to one of the uh preset character preset
meta-human characters and animating it
with his facial performance uh so you
can this becomes sort of the ecosystem
of preset character uh unreal's live
link face up uh your ability to map your
performance to your meta human character
you can also link your meta human
character to other full-body motion
capture workflows uh so you can actually
develop pose animations that kept
capture based on sort of real-time
motion capture
and then these software
ecosystems
are compatible with other development
tools like maya and motion builder so
you can sort of do some re-plotting or
fine-tuning and that's the sort of
nature of this sort of meta-human sort
of creation
is it has to play well with other data
ecosystems at the same time it has to be
rendered and published
inside unreal engine in order to comply
with the company's
licensing agreement
moreover again as i mentioned
epic continues to foreground the value
of all of its other services
that allow you to run this application
through a circuit of relations that
includes not just what three lateral has
given it but also what cubic motion
another acquisition gives it in terms of
facial animation technologies
it has acquired a number of other
complementary companies that include
twin motion for its real-time
architectural visualization software
um epic recently acquired quicksilver
for for its mega scan library of 2d and
3d gram photogrammetry assets so what we
have in the epic arsenal is a
consolidated robust suite of 3d content
creation tools
created in a inside the hermetic data
system that is both people
and motion and environments and an
object asset library all of the elements
are blended together and again as i
pointed out so that we can start to see
epic games as one of many parties
looking to colonize the metaverse
um
before i sort of wrap this up i want to
suggest that you know epic of course is
not alone in its pursuit of building the
metaverse and populating it with human
assets
people selling people is unity is open
source human centric synthetic data
generator this is sort of a sampling
from unity technologies this was
released to the public just earlier this
year
and what unity provides and those of you
who work with unity unit unity is also a
you know
an engine based game developer who is
using its engine based tool
other environments and other build
environments what unity provides with
peopleson's people is a similar are
simulation-ready
3d human assets that are coupled to a
parameter parameterized lighting and
camera system meaning you can take an
asset you can drop it inside any
environment and it's it's coupled to
lighting and camera so you're not going
to lose that sort of the fidelity
relationship between your character and
environment
the 3d human models that we see here in
peopleson's people
are all drawn from a subset of the
what's called the render people library
the reason we call is called peopleson's
people because it's anonymizing the data
so
these may be based on real world scans
of
photogrammetry scans of real people but
by anonymizing the data these become
sort of neutral objects that cannot be
associated or reattached to any one
individual so the 3d human models that
unity is using are drawn from a subset
of render people
and for those of you who have never
shopped for pre-rendered people uh this
is the render people library render
people has its own 3d people library
products that are built from 3d
photogrammetry scans which are sort of
high resolution scans
of more than in this case 4 000 live
models that can be inserted into a range
of 3d visualization product projects so
again in this case
you can purchase a model in the render
people shop and you can drop it into any
you know sales environment any sort of
interactive environment that that you
want again these are based on sort of
real models uh so in the render people
environment you've got a sort of real
actor who can act as a sales person or a
or a host at your university campus
on a virtual tour you don't have to
build that model and it can be
synchronized with your environment
peopleson's people what it does is
simply
thinks about sort of the ethics or data
privacy by anonymizing the data from the
render people models
modulating the appearances of its
virtual people to create more
customizable data sets and that it also
allows you to train the models to adapt
to a specific specified environment so
we can then generalize the model to that
domain so it can fit almost any domain
um
as i close i just want to say that sort
of game engine i think this is sort of
an important beyond sort of although i
focused on people
game engines and their data
infrastructures are really the building
blocks for the metaverse and developers
like epic and unity are using their
engines their assets their data holdings
to claim territory and as i pointed out
to buy up competing or complementary
technology companies to really secure
these hermetic world building systems as
i mentioned in 2019 they acquired quick
cell so they added this world atlas of
high resolution 3d scans of
environmental specimens you know
surfaces materials objects and
vegetation uh unity in 2021 announced
its plan to acquire weta digital and the
the company's proprietary visual effects
suite
stating its intent to unlock the
potential of the metaverse so what we
find
unity and epic both doing is again
building these people models and then
acquiring these robust asset libraries
of urban and natural environments a
flora and fauna of man-made objects of
materials textures and more to really
have this sort of robust sort of
architecture that is a fully fledged
architecture
in my from my own perspective i turned
to critical media studies beyond sort of
studies of production
because i think at the end of the day we
need to interrogate the formal and
structural properties of these texts and
at some level we need to understand the
production process and that's i hope
i've given you sort of some insight into
what what happens here this is the sort
of animation retargeting that i've
talked about so this particular
meta-human character can be mapped to
almost any and any other meta-human
character can be sort of re-targeted
with the same animation rig the
universality of type but i think it's
important to ask whether a tool that can
produce multicultural subjects
is really empowered to produce
substantive social change and create
counter narratives that challenge
existing racial and ethnic and ethnic
inequities i think these questions are
are pressing in this closed circuit of
relations because human assets are being
fabricated from the same identical
algorithmic architecture as their
virtual world
and they're being constructed from and
operating within the same governing data
structures and as i said you know the
promotional materials that surround the
release of epic metahuman creator
focus on in on what characters look like
and how plausible they are rather than
what they're doing or what they're being
asked to do and these representations
always lack context
but as the engine driven traces of the
natural world
continue to move toward greater fidelity
into a greater alignment between you
know physio physionomic and mechanical
systems
the power of epics tool is not simply
what it does but how it does it the user
interface
is designed as a direct manipulation
tool
where end users can monitor their design
choices in real time
visualize the various sort of character
deformations you know as they move
around these facial markers in the in
the sliders but they don't really have
access to what's happening you know you
know beneath the surface here so the
question is is the metahuman creator an
engine for diversity is it simply a
spectacle of control
uh and where video game technologies
have extended their algorithmic
influence into the machinery of a much
broader media and information economy
and they've succeeded by holding on to
the human humanistic attachments of
these algorithms that make their
software look so welcome and familiar to
many developers and designers who are
struggling with these problems and to
get their products running
so by examining these software systems
and their technologies
that undergird the representation i
think we can begin to understand the
cultural power of code as it gets
written into these data architectures
and then in the case of meta human
creator you know we have to understand
that software is both a matter of
engineering what's happening in the
background but also language you know it
has to be legible it has to follow
certain scripted rules it has to
organize it has to communicate it has to
represent information in ways that make
sense it has to shape all of its image
data into a fixed set of material
relations
that follow the rules of successful game
production or interactive media
production
these creations have to make sense the
bodies have to work they have to perform
without failure
and
you know they have to create really
responsive bodies so there's a broader
lesson here for me in shifting our
attention
to both the the deeper architectures of
game design and development but also
thinking about what's happening at the
image level as well there's a we have to
unpack the privilege that comes with the
ability to really
engage in this machine based identity
surfing
we have to always continue to unpack to
understand that these hygienic or
functional understandable distillations
of the material world you know are based
on sort of an underlying information
architecture and there are other
scholars and critics that you might be
familiar with that have sort of you know
approached this you know jennifer
mulkowski and trey andrea rustworm in
their study of game representation talk
about
we don't want to simply pay attention to
code analysis because if we do that you
know we are thinking that programming is
purely technical and not particularly
ideological and at the same time game
representation
is always tethered to software and
harder so we need to you know
we need to develop and expand our
approach to media studies which you may
already be doing
and try to situate computation and
representation side by side and
understand their interrelated you know
disciplinary histories and practices
understand that digital media have an
outer layer and an inner layer if you
want to think of it that way that
representations are governed by code and
they also are the provenance of both you
know media history and history of
computing
that's why that's what i see going on
here in terms of you know the question
that we have to always remind ourselves
is like what is the level of narrative
possibility are these systems simply
amplifying existing hierarchies of
knowledge and power uh our work with
meta-humans from a design perspective is
commonly limited to the surface level of
interventions with the user interface
but as a counter measure i believe when
you have to think about how these
proprietary software environments are
built we need to strive for deeper
computational literacy and that's if we
want to figure out the design biases of
these imaging systems and consider how
they are operating in and regulating the
world at large
with that i will sort of pause
and hope um you have some sort of
response or some input some questions or
some parallel investigations that you're
all uh involved with so thank you
thank you so much eric that was really
really interesting um
i wanted to ask a quick question that
last um
simulation we were seeing over and over
again of the sort of
robot human and the human human and
they're they're the same right and their
hands are empty but they're it's
simulating like holding weapons right
just like without the weapon being there
um
so i just want to make sure that was
what was really happening he struck me
as very strange right and it points to
like well what are we gonna do with
these responsive bodies that don't
function or or that always function
correctly right and it's going to be
playing games with guns and i i'm not a
gaming person at all so i don't know
like the whole range of epics games
um
but are there
different more um
unusual things that these bodies are
designed
to do
um
are they
when you talked about like responsive
bodies that don't fail i immediately
thought of like pornographic
applications of stimulated bodies and at
that point it occurred to me like oh
yeah this really limited kinds of body
creation would really have a negative
impact if it was used in a pornographic
context where like range of body types
would be
possibly like really kind of all over
the place right as opposed to really
tightly constricted in what you showed
so it's just kind of a little prompt
that might uh get you going on a few
additional thoughts
yeah because
the rigs are there is a tension between
sort of the the
the marketing and the design orientation
of the of the product so what you're
rightly noting is
those sort of uh epic games or unreal
developers who are because what i showed
you is pulled straight from the the last
shot that last animated loop is pulled
from the unreal documentation there's
this tension between like the unreal
documentation that shows you the
traditional there are a couple poses
blended together the assumption is a
particular type of action-based game
play you know whether it's a whether
it's a third-person shooter
there's a certain type of action
orientation written into the
documentation that accompanies that
that's peppered throughout sort of what
unreal is proposing
but you are correct in noting
the the open narrative prompt is as long
as there's a rig these characters can be
made to perform in any way
the limitation there is
um back to the unreal engine
architecture if they have to be sort of
published within unreal uh what are the
limiting contours of the unreal engine
that allow or disallow certain um
bodily performances
thank you um i see she has her hand up
hi eric thank you so much for being here
um my name is trishty i'm a grad student
here and i've actually been writing my
thesis on virtual production for the
last two years so i've been tracking a
lot of what you're talking about and i'm
hoping that my question might be able to
like mitigate some of the the blocks
that i i'm not able to understand in
your argument you've given you've sort
of noted a couple of different aspects
right narrative possibility embeddedness
and code propriety information literacy
marketing these are all very different
studies and angles to the same issues of
power so what exactly
are you arguing because there are
multiple layers to the arguments of
power within that so maybe that question
will help mitigate my my hesitation to
respond thank you
yes
for me it flows from i think the the
overarching um
i think all of these are connected
together um
for me it's it's about the
it is about this um
it's about a data ecosystem and so it's
so the big picture is who owns and
controls
data writ large
so it use and that's sort of the
it is a fascinating field because you
know you know being immersed as you are
and studying virtual production which is
constantly evolving
um it it seems at first the space
my initial argument used to be around
game engine technologies is that um
the space for radical possibility closes
as you move through the development
pipeline and that's typically the logic
of
of game development like you have this
rich and open engine based architecture
that is just a
software framework that again gets
connected to a
to a designer that gets connected to a
story so the the radical possibility
shuts down at every stage of the
development pipeline so software
frameworks are open they get formalized
as an engine they get attached to a
particular
intellectual property and that then
pushes them
within a particular genre that then
makes them tell a particular story
around so it was closing down of a queer
or expressive possibility
in ways that if you were just to take
the unity engine and use it as an
independent developer
that possibility is still there although
sort of
the question becomes as these as
unity and epic no are no longer simply
in the business of producing an engine
and you know crytek produced an engine
unity produces an engine epic produces
an engine uh rockstar games produces an
engine
as they start to acquire
you know in this case an epic game you
know quick cell
and you know the three lateral
as you as an independent developer
or artist you know
start to look outward for other types of
influences or assets or libraries or
data flows that may make your object act
differently
what you find is those things are now
shared within the same ecosystem so
it it's not simply oh i'll have to buy
everything from unreal it is as well
unreal starts to shape what those
products can do
so while three lateral used to be an
independent serbian-based company that
could like who knows what we might do
with 3d scanning well now that is
not just acquired by unreal but asked to
do and not do certain things as part of
the sort of epic games mission statement
and that's sort of the
so you're right it's the complexity
because there's that but then there's
like well what is the space for
expressive possibility when
documentation
and i say i study some documentation
that tells users that explains like okay
as an independent developer what should
i do with this tool
well you start by reading through
documentation that then pushes down a
particular pathway that says
click here then click there so the the
element of exploration starts to shut
down and documentation and marketing and
i think all these things
it's it's hard you're right it's hard to
stitch these together because they they
you
run up against different um critical
assumptions driven by different material
histories you know different bodies of
but i think we have an obligation to try
to start to stitch some of these things
together uh and that's
it's interesting to feel the virtual
production like you know
because mandalorian and westworld are
working with unreal
so you may have a a vision or a
storyteller or a filmmaker
um
who's working with intellectual property
that
now has the unreal technician on set
who can then say we can do this but not
this so you start to determine
possibility
in virtual production not based on
in some instances what lucas wants to do
but in other instances what the pairing
with unreal and epic games
suggests the technology can or should or
will do
based on you know history of
conventional use
i don't know if that cuts any closer but
it is a
extremely complicated landscape as
more and more of the
the so the underlying data sets get um
um
conformed in ways that we simply don't
see
okay so i just wonder how it it's
different to pre-existing you know maya
workflows where there were also
artifacts that said do a b c and d i
mean any
deployment of technology involves an
author authority over the workflow
that's any that's not that's even zoom
technologies right click
click the mute button when you don't
want to be heard like that so how are
you distinguishing this has been any
different i guess is my question
they're similar in terms of their
underlying architecture as you point out
yes zoomed in my my first work my first
you know book on transit images was
about like online memorial archives so
how does the sort of architecture of a
911 memorial
where or a
a virtual sort of
remembrance
online where all of your personal images
get conformed to a particular template
like that's sort of the first iteration
of this process of normalizing data
according to these pre-built
architectures
i'd say the difference here so
zoom and facebook you know and
match.com like online dating sites all
conform information
and we can see that sort of ideological
imperative meaning
there's a pre-built architecture that
we're all asked to work within and you
know
but we see but we understand that
negotiation at work i'd say for me it's
this object of
of of authenticity or very similitude
um that starts to conceal what's
happening because
it's one thing to have it in an
interface culture where we understand
the distinction or see the radical
distinction between
ourselves and the representation on
screen
as those divides start to break down in
the case of
photogrammetry in the case of
of
of
metahumans
it becomes harder and harder to see the
coding layer
um then it might be in terms of like
what are my ch
like these become much more
comfortable pre-built assets
um
and we start to
maybe not as scholars but i think more
and more deliberately the the
architecture becomes so complex that we
start to move to default mechanisms that
are handed to us
and i think
in
especially within the realm of story
that becomes a much more dangerous arc i
think of simplification
um i think that
ah there we go tomas yes
thank you and thank you for a fantastic
talk and i'm interested in in your
publication that you know these
algorithmic bodies are anatomically
coded and that this restricts you know
some fluidity or queerness of some
transcendence of code but i wonder if
you know if humans are coded right we
have dna or our anatomic possibilities
are not internet so i wonder the problem
here is uh it's a reference on humans
that and and and if that is the real
real like challenge here
what are you sort of uh what are you
postulating there
well my question is if if if if there is
a possibility of designing a replication
of a human that is not uh anatomically
coded and restricted right given that
humans are restricted by a code with
just dna right we are you know
we don't have infinite possibilities our
our physical bodies cannot be
you know there's a limit in the
queerness of our physical bodies um
and i i wonder if then if the problem
that we are talking could be summed up
us you know the problem is that the
humanity is being replicated and the
physical body has limitations right
yeah
and it is this level of i think what
you're what you're suggesting too is
this is the
so it's the level of remediations that
we're talking about if we have this
complication
within the body itself and then the body
becomes i think it is this
the photogrammetry library the live
scanning of the body suggests that you
can capture
we start to move away from the we're
capturing the materiality of the body
but not its essence of the body
so
so we start we start from with the
scanning library to work from the
surface of the body so it's in multiple
levels of radical erasure
the live so the library is built on
surface scans which which you face that
sort of what you're talking about the
essential problem
and then the metahuman creator all these
3d building tools start to
work from that sort of um
sort of secondary level so it's it's
to try to get back to that the question
then becomes do does narrative where
that possibility gets sort of
reinterpreted or re-encoded
does an agency
always get lost in terms of how these
bodies are constructed but return
somehow in terms of what they do and say
that might complicate how they're built
but is there do you see a conflict there
then do you do you feel that i mean
i don't want to like
translate the conversation too much but
do you think that
that there is a possibility to transcend
that that material aspect of humanity
that this technology is somehow
restricting would that be a correct way
to put it
um
do i think the technology can actually
is the technology inherently a closed
circuit of relations that cannot get us
to a more transcendent is that what
you're suggesting
yeah yeah i would say that i wonder
i mean ultimately at the end of the day
is there
and now you're asking sort of a sort of
an alternative sort of language like
is there an expressive possibility that
simply
is that potentiality out there and not
realized like uh and i think that's a
it's a good prompt um i think it's
it's antithetical to the work that good
that um
engine based design ultimately does i
think this is the the role of artificial
intelligence
two is always the sort of simulation of
uh intelligent behavior means it has to
be logical behavior that there is no
sort of a space for for illogic or
uh incorrect or um or failure
so i'd say it's the nature of these
elements that they
they can may not ever be able to push to
that end
thank you
um
we have a question from paul and then we
have one from laurel carnegie that's in
the chat box so maybe we could uh start
with paul
sure thank you for the talk there's just
so many interesting directions this can
go in
i wanted to ask more about the push for
hyper realism and sort of the
familiar and legible form of hyper
realism that really came out strongly in
the way these interfaces are designed i
work on
been looking at 3d media production in
japan where it's often
the the fixation on realism seems to be
a very sort of american thing it's not
like we could be making anime characters
instead why do we need to do this so i'm
curious what what you see is driving
that is it more
sort of the history of uncanny valley
discourse and trying to stay well away
from that by
not letting you actually get there with
the interface or is it more that that's
clearly where the the big money is to be
able to make completely sort of
plausible realistic characters as
opposed to something that's maybe a
little
a little more
unfamiliar to people or what what is
what is driving the need to keep it sort
of safely hyper-realistic
um
that's a that's an interesting question
and and i
you know i
at some level even in terms of the
from my perspective i think it's the
it's the origin story of these
technologies
and so the in the larger
the largest quest of ai development in
general and and it's sort of uh in a
relationship with um
with either game forms or game
technologies you know ai you know games
are a testing ground for ai so they
ground it in terms of particular sort of
questions
i think the fact that epic and unreal
are grounded in game space
you know is largely
and i say this with an understanding
that
even from
japan if we talk about capcom you know
um capcom has always at least in its
video game space has has pushed
um in its engine development um towards
greater and greater hyper realism
so i think i think it's the legacy of
where these tools and what industries
they're coming out of
uh is orienting orienting them to a
certain sort of
i think that's where the push is coming
from
so i think there is a particular bias
within these in within these particular
game industries
that is shaping that that is pushing the
technology or attaching that technology
to that sort of visual bias
um
that is simply getting replicated in in
and aligning them with other media other
entertainment industries
so
you're right there is a possibility in
all of these engines in working in a 2d
way
but that seems to be be obfuscated by
now the attachment of
i think it's the level of commerce
of unity or epic games and unity to
other other parts of the entertainment
complex
that are sort of prioritizing certain
types of project models i think will be
an interesting test case in terms of the
metaverse in terms of what is satisfying
and not satisfying in terms of a like
what's the visual logic of the what's
the visual vocabulary of the metaverse
i think it will be an interesting push
to see if that becomes more and more
aligned with what we're seeing
in the photogrammetry of the metahuman
creator or whether it still remains this
sort of the sort of other space
uh um
and and without getting too far off i
think sort of the fact that sort of
fortnight
and epic games
have investments in that in that sort of
material direction
i think there's going to be a strong
push in terms of epic controlling the
visual vocabulary of what happens in
those other spaces
but i think that's where it stems from
it's this the origin stories of these of
these tech companies
um
thank you eric from laurel we have this
question i'm going to read it aloud
sorry for the technologically
rudimentary question but i'm curious
about the specific mechanisms of an
algorithm determining a quote plausible
face do you have any information about
how this plausibility is specifically
codified and at what point in the
process is it based on humans manually
reviewing edge cases is there a
possibility for users to push against or
override that plausibility within the
meta human creator as released or is it
too late by the time the data set
reaches the user's hands
that's an excellent question and i can
sort of
radically simplify that um
by first saying that the
um
it is done by
initially with the initial
photogrammetry scan so it's based on
existing um
human physiognomy
that gets sort of captured so there's
the original scan library
that has some element of correction in
terms of sort of humans reading through
and you know reviewing those edge cases
to create the at
within in the creation of the initial
library
and then once those edge cases are
corrected
then the ai learning model takes over
and then can replicate those edge cases
and eradicate those edge cases over and
over and over again
so there's the initial human
intervention that sets up the machine
learning model that then identifies the
edge cases then it can slowly but surely
make sure they get filtered out if you
look at the and
they're the all the sciogan which is i
think a good place to look at this
all of the documentation is on the
github website so if you go to this
person does not exist and click through
you can ultimately find the
uh the
coding database on the nvidia style gans
site
it's all open source
the possibility to push against or
override that plausibility
it becomes non-existent in the med human
creator and they talk openly about this
is that you you can't create an odd
result it will always
there are
they have set the sliders they have set
the parameters in ways that do not allow
you to push
too far or to push the limits of
plausibility
um
so the functional possibility
it is in fact too late by the time the
data set reaches the user's hands in the
case of the metahuman creator
um now what you can see is some people
exporting this is back to the maya some
people then export these things these
assets into maya where you can do a bit
more
subtle manipulation so there's a way of
regaining some agency over your
character by pushing it into maya
and i mean in terms of plausibility like
is is what's defined as plausible um is
it possible that someone um
might be fat is it plausible that
someone might have a hair lip or
you know any kind of any range of of of
disability
because their idea of what's plausible
seems like a certain very normative idea
of
obvious right it was a certain kind of
perfect body that is
you know with a certain body mass index
and so on and just curious you know with
the sliders is there any possibility for
someone you know who has a limp for
example
yeah well they have different um
body types they have a range of body
types body sizes and shapes in their
asset library so you can in fact sort of
mix and match
there are certain limits to how far
again you can push on those
and then
the
what the body does and how it performs
is then
simply a matter of the rigging so you
can
perform deformations to the body in
terms of how it moves because that's not
controlled by meta-human creator but in
terms of when does
the the when does a
um an ear or nose no longer look like a
nose those are things or or lip there is
the sort of normativizing function in
terms of all of the
basic facial features again this gets
back to the ai sort of training model if
it can no longer recognize it
as
this particular
facial attribute
it becomes a it becomes the sort of
marginal case it becomes
uh
no longer plausible becomes an edge case
that cannot be
is not part of the the data set so
there are limits on to what extent you
can
i don't want to say i use deform simply
in the technical sense
but again moving out of meta-human
creator into maya you can then start to
change surface surface texture you can
change
you know
clearly you can add scars to a face you
can deform a face you can do all of
these other bodily deformations that you
might not be able to do in metahuman
creator
the the issue for me is is often that
that becomes a second level of of
of confidence of literacy to know how to
take the asset from unreal and move it
into maya deform do the deformations and
the additional rigging here and then
export it back into so
those who have the utmost literacy and
competence or those who can push
the bodily transformation the furthest
whereas most of us are set with
and using sort of these default
parameters
all right thank you
laurel says thank you and we have a
question from the um one of the
attendees who's not a panelist um
aguinaldo melo
um at the beginning of your presentation
you presented the possibility of
replacing human actors with ai
meta-humans what would be a meta-human
actor without the unpredictable
narrative layer inherent in human
personality
an interesting question um and at the
moment
actually unreal does not allow you to
use its metahumans as intelligent agents
which is interesting so they've drawn a
line in the sand where
um you cannot use a metahuman as your
sales force
or your your uh your ai agent on your
university tour so there there seems to
be some sensitivity to that
to faking people or tricking people into
thinking the media so it has to be used
within a particular type of let's say
sort of fictional context where you
understand the meta-human as a character
and not an agent not an intelligent
agent
um
um
i'm losing the threat on the question
but it's not
so
replica studios with the automated sort
of the the ai sort of voice control that
uses the human actor is subject to the
same condition since they're working
with the meta-human character or still
as a character within a story as opposed
to an agent outside of a
sort of a narrative construct
so i think the question about what an ai
agent might do in a
uh
in a sort of erratic or unpredictable
way
is attached to the context that they're
inserted and
the best that i can do in terms of like
there are multiple use cases but
if these characters are traditionally
because again we're talking about a game
company if these characters are
traditionally being used as non-playable
characters or companion characters
within a game narrative for the
character to act too erratic within the
game and be too unpredictable
is going to lead to less than um
satisfactory gameplay for most
traditional
you know triple a video games which is
where you would see these characters
like
the character has to make sense it has
to be beatable it has to be
understandable uh it can't act
erratically because that can result in a
certain amount of displeasure in
traditional aaa game titles so
i think the narrative context might
determine
to what extent a certain level of
erratic behavior
might be allowable but also uh
acceptable
depending upon that sort of
the context of its use
um i would say the same about like a
university tour like you have an
intelligent agent like do you like
someone wants some continuity at work
there what would be the
acceptable context in which the
character might act more erratically and
we could there are likely use cases
where that could happen
and that that would be acceptable
thank you um
another question
yeah i just i just occurred to me and
i'm wondering what your thinking was
behind using the word colonize in
association with these companies are you
building off of
your existing theory or like why not say
control why colonize that's a heavy word
um i use it in the sense that um
to me colonizing suggests the way that
they are um
acquiring assets and i use the example
of the metaverse because the fact that
they may own the environment or the
virtual stage and they can populate that
stage
with with characters and then they can
populate that stage with environmental
assets and
objects
for me the notion of colonization
suggests a certain um
pleasurable engagement or willful
engagement with an epic games metaverse
so it has a map certain
i wouldn't say com a certain complicit
nature
in terms of the agreement if we want to
engage in these spaces
if we want to have an avatar in the
metaverse
we there's a certain willful adoption of
the platform it's a very seductive
adoption of the platform
and for me that's that's the power of
the sort of the colonizing influence
it's not it is there is an element of
control but there is a this
suggestion of a complicit agreement
between
those who want to participate in the
tools with which
they are able to participate
and the ability to then think about um
if it becomes a branded
metaverse construction
that the limits of engagement are based
on acquiring an epic games avatar to to
participate
or a fortnight avatar which is owned by
epic like
it seems more about your your pathway to
entry um
uh is a matter of like
who owns and
control doesn't feel like the
appropriate there is an element of
control written in there but i think the
notion that possibility gets written out
in terms of entry points to me feels
more like a colonizing force
um i think we have a question from tomas
yes thank you um so i'm i'm personally
very interested in questions of
governance around the metaverse and i
think the questions are on what 3d
assets and what not what 3ds are not
approved i think that's that's deeply
interested
but i think there is something to
acknowledge that the labor behind the
the 3d assets is going to be have to be
done by someone um so i i mean and that
that is probably how to be a company
like a real right like that's i mean
this probably have to be engines uh i i
was recently playing around with uh
decentraland which is uh which is a
metaphor metaverse inspired application
that works on blockchains uh it's very
interesting but the engine that runs
that it's um it's it's unreal i mean
it's there's no meta humans involved
because it's uh it's a 3d space but um
but um but yeah um so i wonder if if the
question here is it's about like
aesthetics about the potential
aesthetics of uh of what meta humans can
do or if it's a question more about
about about governance of of uh
cyberspace right and and we can you know
we can and we can narrate down on on on
the meta version say that it's a
question about about the politics of
what assets get validated and what
assets don't get validated right
i would answer that by saying yes i
agree i agree it's about i think it's
it's both it is about data governance
um
i would say unfortunately the data
governance um
conditions often get radically
simplified in terms of
they get typically centralized around
issues of um
data security and data ethics
and when they typically typically skirt
the questions of representation
in
in in these other sort of in at least in
the policy debates about ownership of
data because those are easier questions
i think those are i would say easier
questions that might be the wrong word
but those are the traditional policy
questions that we ask about information
space
and we ask less about what our assets
are what assets are allowed and what
they can do there
typically first and foremost get reduced
to questions of ownership and privacy
that's that's super interesting
it makes me uh think of this analogy
with this is it this in context
moderation right like what you can say
on the internet and what you can look
like on the metaverse there's they seem
to be
the similar questions
yeah and i'm aware that um is it
facebook just introduced uh boundaries
um
um and uh
boundaries are
that's an interesting question about
sort of
i haven't really thought about this so
i'm not going to talk about it because
it's going to sound like another thought
but
that's an interesting question where
data governance in governance of
behavior
meets sort of the question of around the
representation of self around the avatar
so it's an interesting moment where
data governance
the questions of ethics
and questions of bodies and
representations start to come together
at least in that instance we need to
build a policy around
behaviors which is not a
which is now as a sort of a visual it
takes a sort of it takes a visual form
it becomes embodied you know in that in
that space
great thank you
um do we have any more questions
thoughts to share i don't see anyone
else from the um
off-screen space
okay well thank you so much eric um it
was very provocative very interesting
thanks for sharing it was really great
um and thank you to everyone for coming
today
and we'll see you next week andrew can
you remind us what our talk is next week
so we can do a little plug for it is it
the podcaster
yeah let me just undo for a second
actual
and before you say that just let me say
i know we've got a lot of
students and grad students in your
program
these are questions that i'm actively
working through i know you're actively
working through similar parallel
divergent questions so i'm i'm happy to
hear what you're what you're working on
respond to what you're working on and
how you respond to what i'm like these
are
these ideas are
constantly in motion so i'm happy to
sort of share and talk more
and uh you know how to heather can tell
you how to reach me and
happy to continue conversations about
the works your work my work however it
helps
that is great thank you eric
so yep we do have another event uh same
time next thursday 5 p.m uh it will also
be
just on zoom so not in person just don't
do and that's with jorge caraballo who
is former gross editor at radio ambiente
which is latin america's most popular
documentary podcast
his talk is entitled how to use audio
storytelling to cultivate a community
and keep it engaged
great thank you all right well i'll see
the grad students there next week and
hopefully some of our guests will be
there as well and thank you again to
eric and
offer you some virtual applause
thanks
bye